it's not easy designing a new helicopter
especially if that helicopter has to
survive a ride on a rocket
deploy from the perseverance rover and
be controlled by these guys
200 million miles away nasa's ingenuity
is the first machine aerial vehicle
to fly on a planet outside earth its
more than
500 parts are all designed to meet the
challenges of flying on mars
ingenuity's been so successful in the
past month that it's preparing for
even more flights so why did nasa decide
to design a helicopter for mars
to prove that we can it's a simple
answer
wired talked to jpl engineer teddy
zanetos
to learn about the challenges of
designing a helicopter for mars
there is no manual there's no
instruction sheet no you know
nasa hasn't done this before it's an
evolution of baby stepping
and tackling the next biggest technical
challenge
each step along the way in the month of
engineering getting our flights
has been on one side of the screen
putting up our models
and saying this is what we think a
helicopter should do based off of
everything we've done here on earth and
then on the right side of the screen we
put up
the actual results and we say okay this
is what this is what ingenuity actually
did
and you line them on top of each other
and it's an almost
perfect match
[Music]
one of the biggest flight challenges
engineers had to face
were the aerodynamics of mars the
martian atmosphere is one percent the
density of earth's atmosphere
you know you move your hands around here
on earth you can kind of feel the hair
on your hands moving around as a result
of
every action has encompassed the
reaction right you feel you're actually
pushing the wind imagine now one percent
of that
sensation on your hand that's how little
air we're talking about
flying on mars is like flying a
helicopter at one hundred thousand feet
on earth so there's not a lot of air to
produce thrust to move up so to give
yourself the easiest job possible
you want to keep your vehicle light and
that kind of means around the area of
two kilograms
ingenuity weighs less than your
domesticated cat
the blades have to be compact enough to
fit into the rover
but also fast enough for lift that means
that your blades can just spin
you know around you know we're talking
about 1900 2800 rpm that's super fast
compare that to the rotation per minute
of helicopter blades here on earth
which spin between 400 to 500 rpm
most people are familiar with a single
rotor spinning and then a tail rotor
that counteracts your yaw torque those
two rotor systems if they counter rotate
they can
cancel out that yawn stead and then can
also produce thrusts on top of each
other and still give you positional
control
in its first five flights ingenuity's
flown a combined
91 feet which all together would be
about the height of an eight-story
building
another surprising aerodynamic challenge
was low gravity
it's actually nice that the gravity is
less uh
on the surface of mars it's about
one-third what we have here on earth and
that makes it easier for the vehicle to
actually get up off the surface that
makes it difficult for here on this
for here on earth though because how do
we test that uh we don't have
anti-gravity
technology where there's no way to
cancel out the gravitational field
so engineers built a gravity offload
system to replicate the low gravity
during the testing phase
you can think of it like a high-tech
fishing reel we attach that several
stories above the helicopter in our
vacuum chamber
and there's a control loop that many
many times a second it just
senses how much torque it feels that
torque over a fixed radius pulley gives
you
the tension on the line and we just have
a controller that's
dialing in that torque to give you a
fixed tension and that fixed tension
cancels out the difference in gravity
between earth and mars
engineers also had to make sure that
ingenuity was stable enough to take off
and land without falling over
when after we first landed on the
surface was for the ingenuity team was
to do
our our kind of flight zone selection
that whole site selection process
was very particular about the number of
rocks uh
at certain distances apart as different
sizes of rocks
to give us the best you know location to
fly on
and what about those infamous martian
dust storms
hollywood tends to exaggerate a little
bit the capabilities of mars windstorm
because of that one percent density
there's not a lot of
matter hitting you right and there's not
a lot of momentum being imparted upon
you because of that
so so we're not too concerned about a
dust storm coming and knocking us over
not only did engineers need to make
ingenuity fly
they needed to design a way to keep the
craft from freezing every night
a lot of no pun intended energy but a
lot of time was put into designing the
thermal management
system for ingenuity mars can get to
negative 130 degrees fahrenheit
and engineers how to protect the brain
of ingenuity which holds its camera
computing boards and batteries the
solution
wrapping the box that holds the
ingenuity's brain with
two layers of this shiny golden material
we have our metallized polyamide film
that's our inner insulation layer and
then we have an
outer insulation layer by preventing
those circulation currents from flowing
you
minimize how much heat winds up leaking
out to the outside surface
and you keep your precious components
warm throughout the very very cold
nights
beyond just keeping the battery warm
engineers also needed to keep the
battery
charged the solution was a solar panel
that's our our font of energy that's
where ingenuity recharges it's a
rectangular panel
and it's about a foot long you know i
would say a little less than a half a
foot wide whenever photons are hitting
the surface of the solar panel
we're we're taking those in and we're
shoving them into the battery you'll see
three rows of solar cells on top and
those three rows
all combine to give us all the energy
that we need to charge soul after salt
one single cell of a battery is about
half the life of a cell phone battery
and that's what we use every single
flight every single day every single
moment to keep ourselves warm
to run telecom uh to to speak
back with you know mission control here
on the ground and finally
engineers had to figure out how to
control the helicopter from roughly
200 million miles away
so we have our solar panel with our
little telecom antenna on top and that
is our link
back to mission control here at nasa jpl
all of the data and commands
sent here from the ground we uplink that
to the orbiters orbiters then relay that
to the
rover and then the rover sends that to
our base station which then sends it
back
over to the helicopter everything that
ingenuity does on mars is done
autonomously by code and algorithms
and the engineers at jpl wait for its
transmitted data to see if their
calculations were correct
that's what they're doing here this is
downlink we've pulled in
data products from mars 2020
a little insider baseball here depending
on the size of the data we
sometimes know how things went we're
sitting there at our stations
waiting for the first bits and then the
last bits
to to hit the deep space network to hit
the receiving stations here on earth
to then get forwarded over to jpl once
once we verify data's down
and and our pilot has confirmed that
we've flown then we can celebrate and
say yes now we know for sure
[Music]
however there are even some challenges
that you can't prepare for
after we were dropped the rover took
some very nice images
of ingenuity and specifically of the
solar panel and we noticed that yeah
there was definitely some dust there
that we think
may have accumulated either after we
were deployed
and we're looking right now we're doing
the the data mining analysis one of the
cool aspects of having all this data you
can go back
looking at how did the solar panel do
before flight one before we really
started
shaking the system and then after flight
one how does that change
that is definitely one one of
interesting aspects of having
an aircraft is that you're not
physically static you
maybe can use your propulsion system to
try and clean off your solar panel but
but we'll see
work to go
when ingenuity flies again it'll kick
off its operational demonstrations phase
where the craft will capture images and
scout above the martian terrain we've
proven that
humanity can fly on mars we're trying to
push that envelope even further and
learn as many lessons as we can
eventually parts will fail it's going to
happen right we are
using cod's parts we are not as reliable
as the rover we are not as reliable as a
class a mission that that's designed to
survive
months and months and months right so
it's going to happen we're ready for it
we'll look back to these three points
that
you know we've flown we got the data
down and it's not a fluke we did it
five plus however many uh we're lucky
enough to do in the operational demo so
you know as happy as can be it's been a
dream come true and we're just trying to
continue that as long as we can when the
operational demonstration's over
uh wherever wherever she touches down
for the last time that that's
that'll be where she stays in terms of
the long-term future she's already home
uh so that that's that's where where
ingenuity is meant to be
i can't wait to see what comes of this
and and what you know humanity
can do as a result of this um you know
the idea of being able to carry
meaningful science payloads in the
future maybe one day helping the first
astronauts that land on the red planet
and we're excited that ingenuity has now
enabled that